welcome to this video a new part of
opening disasters and it's again one of
my own games this time I'm a relatively
recent game it's from 2013 a little bit
older than in one year played in April
2013 um it was also in a in a league
game this was the the final round back
then of the German fourth League and it
was a very decisive match it was some
played between opposing club Lipshutz
and my club Dean's Larkin we were both
competing to promotion to the third
league and the winning this match the
final round match would guarantee the
winner the promotion at the end we won
the match very nicely actually and this
game was quite important for therefore
the outcome let's have a look I'm black
and my opponent is Heine Matthias he's a
feed master but he was rated almost 2400
quite a long time and at the time this
was played he was like two thousand
three hundred seventy or something so
pretty strong freedom master he all says
God I am norms probably lacking one norm
or something to get them international
master title yeah let's see what
happened in the game we got a scotch
opening and the important thing to know
is that I knew that I was playing him
but I couldn't really prepare much
because he's playing all openings he's
got an opening repertoire basically
consisting about on line with with our
lines it's playing a 4c 4d for
everything the Spanish the Italian game
whatnot and he played the scotch and it
was something that I couldn't have
anticipated at all yeah here I normally
play this somewhat weird mind
before check know what favorite of Tony
Mart's and I still think that this is a
pretty decent line but it is not as
reliable as the main lines and I had a
hunch that maybe you had prepared
something here so I didn't go for that I
went Knight f6 just the main line
together with Bishop c5 yeah here White
has this choice between Knight c3 the
Scotch for nights on the capture on c6
which is the far sharper option and more
interesting so why took and play d5 the
interesting thing about this is that now
black really has to go Queen e7 which
obstructs blacks development a night
move now does not really help him much
it will lose time in the long run and
the thing is that Queen e7 is basically
forcing white to play Queen d2
so both Queens are somewhat misplaced
yeah okay black has to go 95 not not
much to think about them yeah and here
we come to Worman tour to a point of
decision for white across roads the
dominant main line here which is played
in about 80 to 90 percent of the time
here is c4 you know attacking the knight
very logical move the central last night
is attacked here black has a choice
Bishop a6 and Knight b6 in the game I
would have played Knight b6 because this
is the line that I have studied most
Bishop a6 or ever is also interesting um
still c4 is the main line and hits two
very very sharp interesting claim he
didn't play that however and 92 by the
way is a line that also is played by
some top players with this tries to get
the knight quickly to f3 what place he
fought at a later stage also possible he
played moved
I've never seen before however he played
to move b3 hmm yeah it irritates me a
bit b3
yeah very often this move sort of fits
into the whole scheme of things after c4
very often this pawn needs protection
the c4 pawn so this might somehow fit
into into the position but it's not
clear that it is necessary and I was a
little bit in doubt that this is really
good
probably it is it is still okay but it's
nothing great and it has a concrete
drawback that is exposed quite quickly
yeah after some consideration I went a
five in this position this has some two
ideas the main idea is of course to play
a for the a pawn is slightly weak it's
it's isolated in a way and in like a 4
can be helpful also I'm preparing Bishop
a6 that also might make lots of sense
yeah and what an important thing is that
in this position the move b3 has some
serious consequence for example if we
look at this complete position what
should Y do a very obvious move here is
the move Bishop a3 after that I have a
good reply of the move Queen h4 that's
very important the big point is that
after Bishop takes rook takes black now
has a very very annoying threat and this
is Queen deform it's quite difficult for
white to do something against the threat
also there are sometimes ideas like that
quincy for let's say to cover default
then we have this and all of a sudden
I'm threatening Queen c1 and the pawn on
e5 so shaky business the b3 move in
connection with Bishop e3 has weakened
the dark square so that
that's very tricky what about C form
this looks quite logical and this was
actually the move that I had anticipated
um an interesting moment now I have a
very simple move Knight b6 that actually
transposes to c4 Knight b6 B 3 a 5 yeah
it's one of the the main 9 sanctuary so
it would have been a simple
transposition however my intention was
different when I was sitting there
waiting for him to move I was when I was
thinking when I went a 5 I can always do
Knight b6 but I actually spotted an
eternal turn ative that is interesting I
can't play Queen h4 again yeah quite
funny I can actually sacrifice the night
after the capture Queen d4 it's a very
strong move just just attacking the rook
and there is no good way to defend that
it's quite funny if we consider
something like this the check is oops
the check is going to win for black
immediately sometime like that picks up
everything or if we look at Queen B 2
again there the Czech Knight takes
Bishop c3 and white loses the rook in
the corner so there are some nice
tactics already but white does not need
to take the knight of course he has a
stronger move he has to play a 3 which
is not really great but he has to do
that and then I can play neither form
yeah I've established this the square
now queenie 496 this is probably what
would have happened after something like
that I actually thought that like it's
better because of the weak b3 porn
it can be attacked but in all the
computer is not that enthusiastic it
just gives it all about equal but so I
would have liked to play the position
yeah however this is better than what he
did what he played is the move g3 very
often white is going for this kind of
double fianchetto and well the theater
does make some sense as you want to
cancel at some point but this has really
a very significant drawback and the
drawback is that black can push with
with a for directing now it gets
critical in this position I think white
really has yeah he now has to play
Bishop b2 there is really nothing else
this should be too is at least covering
some stuff like the pawn here and allow
some something to to interpose in case
of a check off before after that the
black know as a choice in the game I was
thinking that this was a good way to
play as the a pawn recapture after the
trade and the check with Queen a5 to
come is really nice for black however if
we look at this we see that this is also
possible which of course is convenient
for for me it's not a problem but after
this and let's say Queenie form and the
trade
black has a nice position we have I have
this great Knight iam but it still takes
some time to Castle this is not
something huge for black maybe a slight
edge but nothing nothing too great it
seems that a3 is even stronger I know
that during the game I didn't consider
this that much but I'm not sure what I
would have done if it actually would
have been played a3 is quite strong
apparently if we look at this I have
seen
and this now is very inconvenient stuff
like that gives black great development
and immediate threats so he has to play
very unnatural stuff like rook g1 for
example black is clearly better here
also there is g6 as a possible way to
quickly develop a very good position for
black a3 is stronger than the caption
still I think he should have done that I
mean the problem is that the position is
is already very very shaky one point to
illustrate that is the move Bishop III
after Bishop III I can take care with
the point Bishop e7 b2 and I will just
win this with a new queen very nice
black hands to take every white has to
recapture and then rook takes a three
wins the whole house check only one and
now we can simply give up the Queen
temporarily and at the end of this black
is enjoying an extra piece yeah tactics
like that are already in the position
and it's all because why this is really
exist behind in development only the
Queen out and this is on not a great
spot and he's got weaknesses on the dark
squares especially there and well g3 is
also not that helpful sometimes if we
imagine the Queen coming somewhere here
yeah he went c4 in this in this position
now and after that I have a direct win a
tactical win yeah and it is relatively
easy to calculate
and I went 8 exp for p3 of course yeah
giving up a piece but it's a simple it's
a simple piece of calculation and white
has to take the the night
all other moves don't really make any
sense it took the knight and the check
yeah and now there are only a couple of
- to consider if we start with King you
one we just give the check and take the
rook quite easy
there is bishop teacher that's also
quite quite simple we just go be - yeah
it's not that that often that you have
after 12 moves the a pawn can be to be -
in promoting yeah this is a very quick
way to finish things yeah so Bishop t2
is also not on what about the Queen
okay here black could give the check and
win the rook but in fact rook takes a -
it's it's even more convincing as rook
takes pawn takes will give a new Queen
as there is a double threat of promotion
and and just capture with the promotion
of me one so also a very quick win so
the relatively best move and this is not
something you you like to play of course
it's 90 - this is what he played at the
end and he I can play b2 to get get
stuff back but it's even easier to play
rook takes a - after that I'm just
threatening to take the rook and the
white really only has rugby one this is
giving me a new Queen very quickly so
rugby one yeah now black can finish
finish off the whole thing with B - yeah
the a pawn really want to move two moves
three moves four moves and touchdown
that's really not not happening that
often yeah um
as I'm also threatening stuff like goo
k1 he has to check on V - this was this
was quite forced yeah and here there is
really nothing that that white can do to
fix things
he took one c6 and after that I am I
made the only mistake in the game early
from from my part
um my move wins but I had a quicker win
I played Queen c1 him which pretty much
guarantees the win as well but Bishop
before was was simpler the ideas to play
Queen see one winning get another piece
on d2 and white has no defense against
that to be honest I'm not totally sure
why I didn't play that I saw the move I
definitely saw it but I cannot really
tell you why I discarded it I had some
and must have had some weird reason but
I don't know what it was
I cannot cannot really remember why I
didn't do that well what I was seeing is
that the check would have played is
winning very easily okay
Queen d1 only move takes his six and
then I attacked the rook and well I'm a
pawn up already
plus the fantastic position and White
has no real move here I still can play
Bishop before next and complete my
development yeah he went the rook g1 I
mean it's just as good as any other move
Bishop before developing this Bishop b3
yeah and here I can play a double attack
on the bishop and the pawn it's not like
he had anything great to prevent it
Quincy - yeah and now this is a little
bit more precise than the check only 5
immediately I just get get the Queen
back a little bit and then take it's a
it's not a huge difference King d1 yeah
and here the computers again merciless
it wants to just play castles I didn't
really want to see the bishop coming to
h7 this however is a winning position
without any doubt the computer is like
+6 or something like I mean it's a
fantastic attack but you have to
understand that it was a situation where
it was of utmost importance to win the
game because our promotion to the higher
league was dependent on the result
and I wanted to play it as safe as
possible so I definitely wanted to give
away some pawn down and then I decided
to play it as simple as possible I just
took this thing on d2 which is not the
best move clearly but it is the the
simplest move King takes yep
after whoops I'm sorry here took with
the king
yeah while Queen takes there is just the
check
winning the rook or forcing a Queen
trade and well twin trade is just the
same as resigning the game I'm two pawns
up so this is a very easy win so he took
with the king and then I saw that the
Czechia is is giving me a useful tempo
King III gap sort of out in the open but
where do you go yeah the the other the
other places are not really really any
better
for example after King e2 i also have
the simple bishop basics and after that
our castle I mean why not just play with
two extra points and and win winning an
endgame it's just a simple way to win he
went to e3
however oops I keep miss clicking this
after the check he went to to e3 after
which I decided to get the rookie into
play and the simplest way to do it is
just King to d8 yeah going to play rupee
eight yeah he played king of three check
on b7 and King to G form yeah it looks
kind of weird but where else there is
nothing really been any better check on
h5 King here yeah now it is a very
forced sequence now Queen g5 intending
made on g4 Bishop f5 was played and now
the final stroke is Bishop f3
yeah after Bishop f3 he resigned the
game the reason is simply that I'm
threatening Queen g4 when the mate
yeah this is the point if he plays let's
say whatever moves like that I'm doing
him Bishop takes and this is a double
checkmate and this was impossible to
prevent it's like a mate and a couple of
moves that computer wants to do is do
this typical desperado stuff which is
not really helping in the long run so
this is the true opening disaster and
it's I think very much due to the fact
that it is difficult to play such a
sharp and and yea demanding opening
where you have yes sort of neglected
your development a bit end you have some
sort of coordination issues what it's
difficult to play that without any
really detailed concrete knowledge and
he's sort of it looked like he tried to
sort of yeah invent stuff over the board
and this is really dangerous if you have
this kind of yeah extreme opening yeah
it can be done in in simpler positions
where there is no direct conflict but
here you're really running a huge risk
of course after this if he now starts to
play best moves like c4 and so on he
still has a playable position but any
misstep is really getting you very close
to the abyss yeah I hope you enjoyed the
coverage of this is quick victory thanks
for watching